it's interesting because I that was one
of my questions further down is
filmmaking your full-time job can you
ever see yourself in a cubicle waiting
for casual Fridays no I can't I can't
see myself doing anything like that
because filmmaking is my full-time job
and when I'm not making a movie I'm
promoting the movies that I've done or
I'm talking on panels at you know
conventions recommending to people to go
out and make movies and I mean I can't I
can't recommend filmmaking as a career
to people unless they know what it comes
with it's not an easy job it's amazing I
never feel more alive than when I'm on
set making a movie but when you're
making a movie that's great but you're
not always making a movie I was very
fortunate from time I made my pure joy
which was my first film until March of
this year I never went three weeks
without what being working on a film so
that was four years of me working on a
film every three weeks I'd have three
weeks in between and I go on to another
film and it was great I mean I flew to
Thailand I did a movie for Animal Planet
I did a bunch of stuff I was doing music
videos in between great stuff and then
like everybody I ended up hitting a wall
in March and I haven't done a movie
since March so it's important to to know
that that happens and you know as as
great as it might feel when it's going
good prepare yourself for when it's not
so you can get through basically what i
like to call the winter because
miraculously in this film industry as
soon as october hits everybody decides
that they don't want to do anything
until january so it's kind of the winner
happens so I think it's important to to
set yourself up so that you can
hibernate
you